you should seek failures  see if you're playing it safe you're not  going to win  if you're playing it safe like that old  saying you know you're talking you're a  little girl  better to be safe than sorry well that's  a bunch of crap it's not better to be  safe than sorry  [Music]  it's by trying things that you figure  out how far you can go  you got to get outside the box like it's  reported edison  tried thousand ways before he built the  incandescent light  he he said he didn't fail three thousand  times he said there was three thousand  different steps to building a light bulb  well there's different steps to get to  where you're going  and i really do treat winning and losing  exactly the same  i do not let it upset me